because of the gaps
hi i'm karina from this humid house and
i'm going to be making a dry arrangement
today
using mostly foraged and harvested
ingredients i'm choosing my ingredients
based on the stunning traditional
fishing basket from hakshong
a local rattan artisan the mechanisms of
this basket are really clever
basically you place the bait inside the
basket
close it with a slid and the fish swim
in
to eat the bait but they can't escape
gorgeous isn't it
because of the gaps in the rats and
weaves it already has somewhat of a
structure in place that we can use to
hold the material which helps the bonus
of creating a dry
arrangement is that you're not
restricted by the type of vessel that
you use
so it doesn't need to be watertight so
we have a lot more freedom so this
basket is really light and i'm going to
use some rocks to
to weigh it down i'm going to place them
in the base just to counterbalance the
ingredients i'm going to be using
i've taken inspiration from this fishing
basket and i'm choosing some
dried grasses because they remind me of
the
grass growth by the sea and on the sand
dunes
we drive these grasses indoors so
they've retained a little bit
of their greenness on my walk this
morning i found this beautiful caesarean
pine
and we love to use kesserina because
it's shapey so the color of the
cassarina works so well with this dried
grass
actually the striations on the leaf have
this beautiful pale green which just
matches
the grass perfectly i've also got these
beautiful
tebow boards and at the wet market today
i got some bamboo shoots
i love them okay and lastly i have
these dried soraco pods i don't know if
you know that the
soraka indica tree is also called the
ashoka tree
and it's culturally sacred to both
hindus and buddhists and often planted
in temple grounds
and used in the liver suffering yeah
i've got quite a few ingredients here
you don't have to use all your
ingredients for me it's a bit like
having
you know a palette of paints i'm not
going to necessarily need all the colors
but i like to have them around so i can
pick and choose
so let's begin first i'm going to start
by weighing the basket down
put a couple of rocks inside
okay now i'm going to actually wire the
lid on because
i want it to be secure i've got a piece
of
wire here which i'm just going to weave
through
the basket next i'm going to attach the
gourds and i'm going to use this
paper rope or it's also called magic tie
i'm basically going to hook these gourds
onto each other
and creates a kind of a lattice i'm
going to add some more gourds
just kind of tumbling down to
break the shape of the vessel a little
bit okay i'm just going to use a
stronger gauge wire
to secure the gourd to the basket
at the back the grass i've got in
different size bundles
and i'm going to start by using a larger
one
in the top of the vessel
it's one thing we often forget when we
do an arrangement we always seem to
look at it from the front but in order
to give it a bit of depth it's really
good to go backwards
i do want to come forward but i don't
want to
put too much in
for the bamboo shoots they have these
tiny little hairs on them that are
basically like
fiberglass so i'm going to put some
gloves on
the bamboo is quite heavy so i'm going
to
basically state that i'm going to put
some orchid wire
so i'm going to place that inside
the bamboo so that when i put in the
basket
it has something to hold it
i'm going to add the catarina now and
i'm going to
add one i think at the top here to give
it a bit of height
it makes using cable ties now because i
want them
i want it to be secure
last but not least we're going to add
the bamboo shoots
i love these bamboo shoots because they
look like horns
and i grew up in south africa this whole
arrangement feels kind of african to me
okay i think we're done thanks for
watching
i should have take easier ingredients
hi everybody i'm francoise from this
humid house
i'm really happy to share today about
how we use plants i will do my best to
articulate the thinking process
as i'm making a plant arrangement so
just a little bit of background
when we first started doing big events
we were really horrified by
how much waste we had so we thought of
using plants
instead of catman tires the benefits of
this is we will nurse
the plants back to health and we could
potentially reuse them again and again
and one of the questions that the design
concealed it
articulates through this exhibition is
are we collectively ready to live closer
to nature
i want to say for you but let me share
some consideration if you want to start
bringing playing with botanical elements
in the house one of the first
consideration
is really the space which is the context
you can have the most beautiful
arrangement if it's
not at the right place it may look like
nothing
and at the opposite you can have
something very simple
but you might be looking at it
differently because it's presented like
a joker
i like to create a nice setup it's
almost like a scene where you want to
create a centerpiece
i would say the most important is light
you need
light for the plant to survive but you
also need light
to appreciate what you're doing let's
talk about the choice of material
most of the time you need to plan things
for events but
today this morning i really wanted to
keep my mind open
it's quite nice sometimes not to think
about what you're going to do and just
to get inspired by what you see in the
garden
and that's why actually when you start
building something
i love to take each ingredient each
material
exactly at the same level even if it's a
vessel or
even if it's a plant so i'm really
excited to show you what i found in the
garden i mean look at this
this is the roots of the tapioca here it
looks like organs
and then you have the stem hair coming
and it looks like a spine
almost looks like the disc that you have
in your spine as well
beautiful and then here you have the
ghost
a phobia have a lot of stones okay and
look at this
this incredible delicate bat lilies
this is right here that looks like ears
and the moustache here and i got this
butterfly wind plants so you have
something very heavy
and then you have a little bit of
lightness but let's talk about the
vessel
if you look at the tapioca textures you
know it kind of reminds me
a little bit of the same but it's also
because it's very stable
and we have actually two very heavy and
core ingredients
most of the time when i'm starting an
arrangement installation
you really like to see the shape of what
you have
i don't know if you realize my gloves is
double layer
of gloves and i will try to see
the shape and how i'm going to use it
almost like a puzzle
so this one looks pretty nice from this
angle
so i will probably use it on the left
side and then
i have this little one as you can see
which has
a lot of [ __ ] and actually could be very
nice by itself
so see how it's going down here you can
see the curve
so it might be most probably going down
like this on the right
okay and you have this one
like really massive one beautiful
awesome look at this
which almost look like a wave and i will
probably use it in the middle
i really love the spine but i might have
to cut it
i can keep it but then i have less
possibility to play around
it's a bit of a shame because it's
actually beautiful
but i can try actually let's try it
without cutting
what i'm trying to do is to do some
space on the bottom because i want to
hide the roots of the gaussian phobia
so i think i'm gonna go it's really
daring but
i'm gonna go for something like this
enough
i'm gonna use as a trick some rocks on
the bottom
it actually looks more natural now when
it's straight like closer
so most of the time when you work with
big plants or big foliage you
always like to start from the biggest
and it's quite nice to
play one by one ingredient so let's do
this one
now so i feel like this one can come
from the back
so you can extend a little bit and if it
works
then you can put it in the pots on the
back
so when you have big pieces like this
it's also always playing with the
balance
and now i have the small one they're
very
a little cutie here with a nice curve
almost something like this
so i'm like really sticking forward in
front
you can always adjust after actually
when you think about plants
it's so big that you don't have so many
options
so you play with the shed first again
i really choose from the biggest to the
smallest
so now i'm gonna do the battlini i'm
gonna keep the leaves but i can only
stream after
and when you think about this you just
want to have an area where you have a
focus pointer
so i will probably focus around that but
so let me try here
i know that i'm gonna have a lot of this
but i'm just removing the one that i've
broken
and let's have another one
oh that's a beautiful one i don't think
you want to go
too wide with the leaves so i'm just
removing the one
and keeping the one in the middle which
are more straight
so i'm gonna try here it may not work
and let's try okay just wanna show it
i really want it to go more on the left
really just to follow actually the
tapioca
but you still want to show the roots so
let me try to put it on the left
i'm gonna try from here
[Music]
okay let me raise it a little bit
so see now i have so much leave so let's
trim a little bit
you really want to show the one on the
back even if this one has a very nice
gesture
i'm gonna have to cut it so i can show a
little bit on the back
and now i'm gonna try to add
a little bit of lightness in this very
heavy arrangement
which is the butterfly one so if you
think about
colors actually i was really looking for
colors it could be a color that you see
around so you see you have a little bit
of yellow so if i have to
add flowers which is actually possible
by putting a glass vessel inside but
i'm just going to keep it simple and
only do plants today
but if it's something that you really
want to keep for
months at home you can do everything
with soil of course
i'm going to hide it here and you just
want to try
to bring a little bit of lightness
i'm going to go there let's do and
something that you really have to accept
it's really difficult to have a pre idea
of what you want to do because
actually what guides you is really the
shape of the plants i mean
this one has a v-shape you really want
to show it so it might be
actually flying and now we probably used
the last one
here so it wasn't pretty so i'm actually
very happy to show you how to break the
plan
it sounds a little bit messy but you can
do it just very simply with a plastic
bag
you can even do it without touching the
sole imagine
as possible so i usually put pots inside
you remove it
then you have this that you want to try
to make smaller and you see the roots
please don't cut the rules so normally i
will put a little bit of water
cable tie and then
you can cut the rest okay and then you
can cut the bag
so this is the last one and you really
want to show that they are flying around
so
i feel like i really want to go high and
it will be something like this
i just found the last part lily and look
at this one
i feel like this is slightly empty but i
really don't want to hide this part
so let me try i think it might be from
here
it's a bit sterilized but let's have one
going down like this
and you have them talking to each other
and you have the little green one here
so to go back to the arrangement when
you look at the arrangement from here
one of the main thing that i always keep
in mind is the proportion
and of course after you play with the
contracts the different colors of the
plants
and you start to compose when you think
about
proportion actually proportion is
something which is very important it's
always here and i truly believe that we
even see
things and judge things because of
proportion we are so
used to have um symmetrical or like
one-third two-thirds
i actually googled and i found this
definition in wikipedia
proportion is a central principle of
architectural theory
and an important connection between
mathematic and arts and
that's really true but it's also the
visual effect of the relationship
of the bias object and space that make
up a structure to one
another and to the whole and it's
actually proportional everywhere when
you're building something
so i really want to encourage all of you
to go
in parts even nurseries and even looking
at the streets to see what you have
outside
we're really looking forward to seeing
what you create for our giveaway
full details of how you can participate
in the caption
a big thank you to the design singapore
and the national design center for this
opportunity
see you soon thank you
[Music]